good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael by one word and believe as I
believe that monsters will solve all of
the world's major problems so help on
your journey today's message is shot
over to hear Tupac Shakur I can't
explain why I shine and no one else I
think everybody shines and different
things and a lot of things I can't do I
can't play basketball like every other
black person in America but I can act
I'm not a go to there to spy myself
because I'm there every day I could be
me I can be whoever because I'm true to
me I can go to Nuuk so easily a lot of
people black white Mexicans young or old
fatter skin you have a problem being
true to themself say I'm probably
looking in the mirror and looking
directly into their own Souls the reason
I sell six million records the reason I
could go to jail and come out without a
scratch the reason I can walk around the
reason I am Lions today is because I can
look directly into my face and find my
soul there it's not sold I didn't sell
it it's still within me I still feel it
my heart is still connected to my body
sock okay any character imma bring that
intensity that truth and honesty to it
because I have to pay for that blessing
from black Jesus from God I have to pay
for that by shining if you give you the
voltage and you waste it that's the
curse he gave me the voltage I'm a son
it's not mine
from God God not that it's so special
that nobody got it but all of our gifts
and blessings and our shrimps and our
weaknesses come from God come from black
Jesus or whoever comes from within you
Namie so it's not really tricky
everybody can do it if they just can go
to that spot I guess all the things that
happen to me in my life
allow me to go there easily I wish that
everybody has genius-level challenge and
something everybody has genius level
talents as something people just don't
know what it is people just coach they
said other talents what is every
discovery I want to say that Michael
Jordan is not the greatest basketball
player of all time the greatest
basketball player of all time as a
manager in covers because he needs
changes basketball dreams or because
everyone together back to back right so
how many people sit on their ambitious
sit under dreams system the desire to
actually take the action you could have
been Michael Jordan's and what you did
but instead you doing this thing is
doing as opposed to the wake up and then
drive for for something don't like in a
job so they don't that doesn't factor I
should have told the people who you know
don't respect them as much addition and
they do that every single day perfectly
like that that's what most people we
come to do that's really sad but if
nobody else it's false
besides your honor I believe to be
responsibility to go and find the thing
if you have genius level talents act as
you can shine with and some of you know
it so we know I can be the best in the
world or among the best in the world at
this you know but you just not take
enough action on it you're not committed
enough to it you're not practicing hard
enough to get to where you want to go my
majority has talent but he's practice he
works harder than but on the bold as
well you got to own your crap and
practice and working every single day so
some of you know what you have the
potential to be great at which you're
not put in the work to get there
you're coasting you reach a certain
level you're coasting
it's easy for you to do that leveling on
the put a lot of practice and
preparation into it you know your other
responsibilities until you're kind of
coastal it's one thing your talents that
some of you doing enough so we have no
idea what your child does you have no
idea what your genius level Michael
Jordan level at and so that's to the e6
for like that mentor Starbucks if he
never picked up a basketball
he would never don't even be better than
Michael Jordan so you can explore you
say yeah she's the try things if you
have no idea what your passion is the
purpose is then say yes to almost
anything your son is legal as long as
that or that the column finally harm you
know it was a few criteria but in
general suggest everything is something
I still try to talk today I say yes to
new experiences
say yes China's new things say yes it's
going to new countries say yes to
triangle food so yes it's going to a new
event so yes until you know you know you
say that to try that the sushi you
figure out all your sushi great don't do
that again
that's the definition of insanity right
it's going back and do the same thing
goes nope again it's like a different
result if you can test it isn't you know
I don't like Ron I don't like the thing
in my crotch and I like the heights I
tried I said yes
I tried it I don't like it great I don't
think we'll do it again but don't know
what it is if you love to you have to
try say yes yes yes until you find the
thing that makes you come alive that you
want to do over and over and over and
over again until you shine you have
might deserve a little talent or
something and it desperately want you to
find it and act on it to make positive
in time not just for yourself but your
community to people around you in your
family and so the question today is I'm
curious two parts one do you know what
you have Michael Jordan level talents
acts and two if you do what is it oh yes
or no questions
the answer leave the comfortable oh I
also want to give a quick shout-out to
the z-table thank you so much as a cup
of my poster one word I really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoy doing so thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you so
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love and as you get far more a for
another shot of espresso
you know my mother used to tell me Todd
you can do anything you put your mind to
and my grandmother used to tell me if a
task is once we're gonna never leave it
till it's done be thy labor great or
small do it well or not at all and I
kind of grew up with that mantra you
know I grew up believing that you can do
anything you put your mind to
hmm you know and I don't um no matter
what you know I am extremely determined
yeah like I'm like you know abnormally
that need to succeed never goes away
right it's not only it's not just a like
a general like success for the sake of
succeeding it's it's a desire to create
yeah you know I'm saying to use the
godly power and talent that was
instilled in me to the best of my
ability to maximize my potential because
if I'm not here to maximize my potential
that woulda my own earth well my message
to you is pretty much manage just follow
your dreams
another thing I think a lot of people
get caught up and gives over sidetracked
by what's happening I'm around them it
was cool people always ignored a gift
not realizing that gift this was gonna
take you out of your poverty take you
out of your situation their gift of the
truth is the ultimate element that God
provided for you to get you out of any
situation or to take you to what's
destined for you you know some people
are just great at certain things but
because music or modeling or film is
cool they a li innate what their gifts
are just to be a part of something that
is pursued to be or persuades to be cool
I always felt like you know my method
and message always has been and is
following the gift that you have put a
lot of emphasizing concentrate on what
you feel that your gradient because what
you're grading is always gonna be will
pulls you out of the worst situation
that you could ever imagine it puts you
in a better situation right when you
fully accept that you are here to be
great when you fully accept that you are
here to be happy when you fully accept
that you're here to receive when you
fully accept that you can have the peace
and the serenity and the joy and the
wisdom and the purpose and the intention
that you intend to bring to the world
and that it is all available to
you that's when life gets very groovy
and so my hope and my intention for
today is to wake you up to that presence
and more importantly give you a really
great New York City kick in the ass
it says not only I'm awake to it not
only do I believe in it
but I am committed to it I am
unapologetic about my capacity to be
great I'm unapologetic about my capacity
to heal I'm unapologetic about my
capacity to see beyond my physical sight
I'm unapologetic about my capacity to
shine as bright as I can shine because I
trust and I know that when I shine
bright I give others permission to do
the same and in my glow they wake up to
and that is why we're here